So now your app gets the data special
out of the tag manager container.
When you update the daily special
variable in tag manager and
republish the container your
app picks up the changes.
But what if your user
doesn't speak English?
Wouldn't it be nice for them to see
the daily special in their own language?
>> Why didn't you say so before?
Now I'm going to have to
update the code in my app.
>> Don't worry.
No code updates needed.
Seriously, to make this change you
don't need to update your code.
We can handle it all in tag
manager using a built-in variable.
So come with me and we'll delve into the
wonderful world of built-in variables.